[Musique]
Bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du VIP que nous
consacrons aujourd'hui à Emmanuel de
valicourt qui est l'auteur de la
princesse de Lamballe la me sacrifier de
Marie-Antoinette Emmanuel de valicourt
ou Bonjour bonjour Véronique merci de
m'accueillir et merci d'être venu alors
vous êtes
hauteur bien sûr vous êtes aussi
enseignant en droit à la Catho à Paris
et j'ai envie de dire un jeune écrivain
russe que ce livre est votre 3e voilà
nous vous avions reçu pour les favoris
de la reine et celui d'avant c'était un
livre consacré à parler ministre de
Louis 16 le contrôleur général des
Finances de Louis 16 le compte de
Calonne
intitulé Le Comte de Calonne la dernière
chance de la monarchie puisqu'il avait
essayé de mettre en place une réforme
pour essayer de sauver le système
institutionnel monarchie qui
malheureusement n'a pas abouti on
connaît la suite ce qu'on avait écouter
seulement non et surtout la cour ne l'a
pas voulu l'écouter mais la cour ne l'a
pas écouté ok alors est-ce qu'on peut
dire que vous êtes un spécialiste de la
société
prérévolutionnaire en tout cas c'est un
sujet qui me passionne j'ai l'impression
que le sujet qui me passionne la société
prérévolutionnaire si vous voulez c'est
quand même il faut dire les choses
simplement c'est événements de la
Révolution et quand même demeure pour
moi un mystère et j'essaie d'approfondir
le plus possible cette société qui
précède la révolution pour essayer de
comprendre quels sont les racines les
ressort des événements qui vont se
dérouler temps à Versailles que à Paris
qui vont entraîner un système millénaire
jusqu'à l'abîme donc
la vous avez choisi la princesse de
Lamballe est-ce qu'on peut dire que
Marie-Antoinette avait deux grandes amis
très proches on avait la princesse de
Polignac cela est la princesse de
Lamballe donc vous avez choisi la
princesse de Lamballe pourquoi alors
d'abord parce que la duchesse de
Polignac avait déjà été traité par
madame Colas des Francs dans une une
très belle œuvre il y a quelques années
et la princesse de Lamballe était un peu
rester en jachère et surtout que est-ce
que j'ai trouvé intéressant c'est que
tout le monde connaît sa fin dramatique
mais elle les massacrer par la furie
Populaire quelques jours avant son 42e
anniversaire et on ne sert à rien ou à
peu près rien de la vie de la princesse
dans ces années qui précède cette
fameuse événements de sa mort alors
j'avais envie de la faire un petit peut
exister et de la réussite est auprès des
lecteurs
une très jolie histoire évidemment
triste mais une belle histoire et il
vous avez une façon de raconter que
tellement fluide qu'on lui ça ah bon
c'est une c'est une biographie mais on
laisse ça comme un roman voilà bon moi
je me suis régalé alors cette pauvre
petite
Marie-Thérèse elle et elle a beaucoup de
points communs avec Marie-Antoinette
déjà on peut dire ça oui elles sont
toutes les deux à moitié allemande oui
absolument ce sont deux princesses
étrangères qui arrive à Versailles donc
Marie-Thérèse va arriver 2 ans avant
Marie-Antoinette et elle arrive à
Versailles par le fait de la
géopolitique et des traité d'alliance et
de la géostratégie des cours européenne
donc ce sont des jeunes femmes qui sont
sacrifiés à la raison d'État en épiant
ce sont des pions
sur l'échiquier politique
le même la même cérémonie
à la frontière de
déshabillé remettre des vêtements
français de parler alors elle est parler
italiano qu'elle parlait sa langue
première c'était quoi alors c'était bien
voilà parler d'abord mais vous savez que
dans toutes les cours d'Europe on
parlait bien sur le français qui était
la langue diplomatique et surtout la
langue élégante pour les cours du 18e
siècle mais elle a été élevé en italien
et en allemand puisque sa mère et
allemand c'est une princesse de
rheinfels Rothenburg et donc elle a été
également en allemand donc elle est déjà
trilingue et elle arrive en France
et en allemand et
ainsi elle
s'est
de se retrouver
il faut pas oublier que Marie-Antoinette
arrive à Versailles donc en mai
1770 elle a 14 ans et demi
sont des adolescents et
plus
à Marie-Thérèse puisque celle de votre
livre elle est alors elle est mariée
très jeune à 16 ans avec un prince donc
le prince de Lamballe pour le meilleur
des parties non c'est pas en parlant non
non c'est sûr que non plus alors écoutez
le prince de Lamballe est un personnage
tout à fait incroyable comme seul le 18e
siècle est capable d'en générer
c'est-à-dire c'était un homme d'abord
qui qui avait été marqué par la
multitude des deux est dans sa famille
il avait perdu sa mère
il avait perdu ses frères et soeur il y
a eu 7 enfants et seulement deux ont
survécu et ses enfants sont morts en
base âge mais pas de nourrisson donc il
a connu tous ses frères et soeur et il a
été marqué par la succession de CDI
familiaux qui ont vraiment marqué son
enfance et sa jeunesse et qui ont créé
chez lui une forme de désillusion par
rapport à la vie
il va si je peux me permettre un peu
trivialement il va bouffer la vie par
tous tous les bouts toutes les manières
possibles et imaginables et il va
surtout avoir une vie sexuelle
complètement débrider une comme on
disait au 18e siècle avec cette
expression assez amusant qu'il va se
retrouver poivrée c'est-à-dire que
traînant dans les bordel à la fois de
Versailles et de Paris on va se
retrouver avec une maladie vénérienne
qui va finir par l'emporter très jeune
puisque il meurt il a tout juste 20 ans
et ils n'ont qu'un an et demi de mariage
donc cette pauvre Marie-Thérèse qui
vient d'être comme je disais à quelques
instants sacrifier au calcul
géopolitique se retrouve veuve
femme bafouée
et voilà alors quel est son destin à
partir de là
elle n'en n'a plus mais oui mais ça
dérange qui personne et ben voilà c'est
ça que je trouve
18 ans elle a 18 ans elle n'a plus de
venir se présente devant tel un certain
nombre de choix elle pourrait
éventuellement retourner dans sa famille
mais elle a fait un mariage avec un
prince du sang donc retourner dans sa
famille est là dans une petite famille
de la branche cadette de la famille de
Piémont-Sardaigne et donc on de lui
retrouveras pas un prince du sang elle
ne peut plus se marier avec un prince du
sang parce que elle ne peux pas te
déranger en épousant au broad de Provins
donc elle est elle est condamné à rester
dans sa belle-famille auprès d'un
beau-père il y a du duc de Penthièvre
pas le gars le plus marrant de la terre
il est pas furieusement gay et c'est un
c'est une belle figure si vous voulez de
d'aristocrate du 18e siècle c'est une
c'est une des belles figures de la
famille royale
dans la famille de Bourbon vous avez la
multitude d'exemple de personnages un
peu
si vous voulez c'est une belle figure
d'accord bon ben écoutez tant mieux en
plus il est
absolument
de Louis XIV
et de Madame de Montespan tous les
autres enfants de 7 ans
avec Madame de Montespan sont morts mais
Louis XIV avait incroyablement de TTC
bâtard et le duc de Penthièvre à réunis
sur sa même personne tous les héritages
avec le nom de Louis XIV on va encore
parler un peu plus de la princesse de
Lamballe maintenant qu'on a brosser ce
portrait il se trouve que elle rencontre
Marie-Antoinette et on peut parler d'un
coup de foudre amical oui qui a duré
longtemps oui plusieurs années et est-ce
que ce qu'il a séduit c'est le côté
loyal et fidèle elle est pas très elle
est pas folle elle est pas pris vol il a
plus beaucoup de temps donc
elle
fait partie de la famille royale
le jour de son arrivée et elle
va être pourquoi parce que
cette jeune femme en lui disant voilà
votre cousine Marie-Thérèse de Lamballe
depuis quelques mois et Marie-Thérèse et
qui est Marie-Antoinette pardon qui est
toujours très sensible au malheur des
autres j'avais eu l'occasion de vous en
parler la semaine précédente interview
va tout de suite est touché par la
situation de cette cousine il se trouve
que Marie-Antoinette aime les personnes
franches fraîche qui sont sans contour
et elle va très vite vous le savez bien
être dégoûté par cette ambiance tout à
fait délétère à la cour de Versailles or
Marie-Thérèse de Lamballe et la
franchise fait femme et ça ça va
beaucoup séduire Marie-Antoinette à la
reposer ça
confirme plot des cours et
surtout de
tout le monde
et
pour toujours
un peu des gens qui l'approchent et qui
va
aller plus loin dans le temps
donc à la fin la famille royale est à
Paris et la princesse de Lamballe contre
la ville Marie-Antoinette rejoint la
souveraine et partage son sort alors au
moment de la fuite à Varennes donc nous
sommes en juin
1791 au moment de la fuite à Varennes
Marie-Thérèse ne va pas être dans le
complot de la fuite à Varennes mais
Marie-Antoinette va lui écrire une
lettre qu'elle recevra dès le lendemain
en lui disant filles et nous nous
ennuyons fuyez donc Marie-Thérèse à ton
père mais il fuit elle s'embarque eu sur
les côtes normandes et elle va rejoindre
la Grande-Bretagne puis ensuite elle
rejoindra les membres de la famille
royale qui sont à Bruxelles et et à
Aix-la-Chapelle d'accord et là en exil
elle se morfond pour la reine parce
qu'elle sait que le roi et la reine en
t'étais arrêté à Varennes et elle se
morfond et la multiplicité des lettres
montre que Marie-Antoinette ne cesse de
lui écrire en lui disant je vous en
supplie protégez-vous ne revenait pas et
Marie-Thérèse va revenir parce que elle
ne veut pas laisser
Marie-Antoinette seule elle aime trop se
traîne à qui d'une certaine manière elle
avait sa vie oui qui a donné un sens à
sa absolument on peut dire ça sur ces
belles paroles Emmanuel de valicourt un
grand merci merci vraiment la lecture de
ce livre qui est très agréable et très
passionnant et peut-être à bientôt pour
un nouveau biographie j'espère aussi
vous avez la gentillesse de m'inviter
avec plaisir c'est toujours chez
Tallandier et à chaque fois c'est un
régal voilà au revoir à tous merci de
nous avoir suivi et à très bientôt pour
un nouveau VIP
[Musique]